depuis quelques temps les criminels
italiens embauchent des migrants qui ont
traversé la Méditerranée je veux parler
des Nigériens en échange d'un voyage en
Guyane afin de transporter la drogue ils
obtiendraient des papiers pouvez-vous me
dire ce que Eurojust peut faire pour
enrayer ce trafic pas seulement de
drogue mais aussi humain pour que rjus
s'agisse il faut qu'il y a un procureur
ou qui prennent la main sur un dossier
puis qui a envie d'en faire aussi un
dossier européen avec des besoins de
coopération he nous on peut pas enfin on
peut on peut un peu c'est ce qu'on
appelle notre initiative propre si vous
voulez c'est-à-dire que je pourrais
décider éventuellement d'ouvrir un
dossier sur ces questions mais si vous
voulez c'est les autorités nationales
qui enquêtent c'est la police française
ou la gendarmerie qui fait les enquêtes
il faut à un moment qu'il y ait une
vraie procédure quoi et après si vous
voulez c'est c'est ces dossiers qui en
fait combinent aussi bien le narcotrafic
l'aide au séjour irrégulier
l'immigration clandestine c'est aussi
l'immigration clandestine ça fait partie
des gros dossiers européens qu'on a hein
ça il y a des réformes si vous voulez
qu'on voit au jour le jour hein ça tout
le monde le sait après vous êtes bien
placé pour le savoir c'est pas toujours
aussi simple que ça on sait bien ce qui
manque mais pour trouver et mettre en
place la loi qui va permettre de combler
ce gouffre c'est pas toujours aussi sain
donc voilà nous notre travail c'est tout
ça c'est essayer de trouver des
solutions on arrive sur les dossiers
d'immigration les dossiers de
stupéfiance je DIRIS que souvent c'est
c'est pas que c'est plus simple mais
tout le monde a des intérêts conjugués
quand on rentre dans les les dossierers
d'immigration clandestine ça n'aura
échappé à personne qu'il y ait une
sensibilité parfois particulière dans
les états et trouver les arrangements
pour que tout fonctionne dans le même
sens c'est pas toujours aussi simple
voilà